un nouvel espace dédié à
l'entrepreneuriat va voir le jour dans
deux mois à saint quentin en yvelines
selon sky tube installé près de la gare
la structure va accompagner de jeunes
startups du territoire il va aider une
trentaine de jeunes chefs d'entreprise
accélérer leur réussite professionnelle
à monter leurs prototypes à
acquérir les qualités de management de
savoir
à avoir leur premier client de travail
en des réseaux d'entreprise
j'aurais adoré avoir un incubateur de ce
type là je pense que tu as gagné du
temps j'aurais été encore plus efficace
ce mercredi soir dans la salle du
conseil de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines une soixantaine de
partenaires de la structure se sont
réunis pour rappeler les grandes lignes
stratégiques de l'incubateur se sont
quasiment uniquement des entrepreneurs
de saint-quentin des grosses entreprises
des moyens
et puis également d'autres acteurs
économiques qui vont jouer un rôle dans
cet incubateur dans cet accélérateur de
croissance de nos prix entrepreneurs des
dizaines de candidatures ont déjà été
reçues pour intégrer skype dans les
prochains mois au total une trentaine de
dossiers sont reclus